welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and losing chadwick bozeman
devastated fans
everywhere especially those of us in the
nerd world whose whole lives revolved
around an appreciation
and curiosity over how the black panther
would lead the future of the marvel
cinematic universe
the news of his death caught us all by
surprise and i have spent these past
couple weeks just trying to respect
bozeman's work
mostly by avoiding speculation about
what marvel studios might try to do next
i mean i didn't even really do a
reaction or a news report video just
because it felt
weird to me to try to spin this when all
i really wanted to do was reflect on
chadwick his various roles and his
struggle
so despite the many requests i've gotten
i have repeatedly just asked the marvel
fans out there for patience on the whole
what happens now question just out of
respect in this video i'm gonna
update you on the whole black panther 2
situation clear up any questions you
might have
try to explain how i am looking at
marvel's future in the context of black
panther but really just to
kind of describe the conversation i hope
we can have about this because honestly
all i care about is respecting chadwick
and amplifying the message that he
wanted us to hear so chadwick boseman
was diagnosed with stage 3 colon cancer
in 2016 but he continued to work on
marvel films like black panther infinity
war and game
the only ones who knew about his illness
were reportedly his family his agent his
trainer and the director of the movie 42
brian helgland
black panther director ryan coogler did
not know he was in the middle of writing
the script for black panther 2
assuming bozeman would return as
t'challa in coogler's statement he said
i spent the last year preparing
imagining and writing words for him to
say
that we weren't destined to see it
leaves me broken knowing i won't be able
to watch another close-up of him in the
monitor again or walk up to him and ask
for another take marvel head kevin feige
didn't know either
he said he found out via email the day
of bozeman's death now bozeman had lost
a ton of weight which did concern many
on social media but bozeman's family
recently said he was convinced a week
before his death that he'd be able to
rally
in return to shoot black panther 2 this
march now many have wondered how it
could be possible this was such a secret
believing that major movie stars must
have to undergo some kind of medical
exam for insurance reasons but it turns
out according to a film finance attorney
the bigger studios like disney don't get
completion bonds and
are more likely to shoulder the risk of
things like sickness or death
like i gotta say i am very uncomfortable
with this conversation moving on to what
marvel studios might do next because
let's face it we don't have a lot of
experience having this conversation
neither does hollywood by the way
this industry has lost actors midway
through development or through
production
they sometimes recast sometimes they
resort to awkward vfx to digitally
insert actors back into the film
sometimes it's done tastefully sometimes
less so
really i see this as a struggle between
two general directions
the logical path and the impactful path
now a number of fans and hollywood
producers are very good at the logical
path it's like they're grabbing you by
the shoulder saying okay look we gotta
recast we gotta move on i don't wanna be
sad anymore we could make this work with
uh resampled audio and existing footage
we can spin this into an adaptation of
like this comic series or launch a new
hero or a new villain or a toy line
there's money to be made let's go go go
go
i do not believe that is the direction
we need to go right now i mean we could
but i don't think we should actually not
to get two cat stevens on you right now
but i think a lot in life is could
versus should
so in terms of the impactful path
forward i think we need to think about
what the
impact of these decisions will be and
even more importantly what
chadwick wanted because he knew how
important this franchise was to young
fans
you've probably seen this clip by now
but he once got emotional talking about
terminally ill fans
trying to hold on until black panther
released to a certain degree
it's a humbling experience because
you're like this can't mean that much
to them you know but seeing how
the world has taken us on i realized
that they anticipated
something great and um
i think back now to a kid and just
you know uh waiting for christmas to
come waiting for my birthday to come
waiting for a toy that was going to that
i was going to get a chance to
experience a video game
i did live life waiting for those
moments and so it put me back in the
mind of being a kid
just just to experience those two little
boys
and anticipation of this movie and when
i found out that they
take your time
yeah it's it means a lot that
says it all he knew black panther was
shared by
everyone it was a celebration of so many
faces so many tribes
it is so meaningful for this title to
live on
black panther 2 might be delayed that is
ok
but it will not and should not be just
cancelled but it also looks likely that
the character of t'challa
might be ending with chadwick boseman
there don't appear to be any plans to
recast
or use cgi to awkwardly like try to
puppet him back to life
if you looked at kevin feige's statement
he said that bozeman was as smart
and kind and powerful and strong as any
person he portrayed
and he now takes his place alongside
them as an icon for the ages
that along with coogler's statement
about writing words for a character that
we'll never
see suggests to me that the director in
the studio are doing a great job keeping
that
impactful path in mind recasting is an
option they could consider
years from now like maybe when all
marvel heroes are being rebooted in some
like alternate multiverse reality
and yeah while maybe a vfx cameo of
chadwick boseman's appearance among his
ancestors on the
ancestral plane could be a very
beautiful and tasteful inclusion but
let's be clear i do
not want bozeman's likeness digitally
jammed into some
weird prologue death scene or for his
existing audio to be chopped up and
re-contextualized like they did with
carrie fisher and the rise of skywalker
and i hate to even be talking about this
but you're already seeing people doing
this with chadwick boseman
that moment in captain america civil war
when t'challa is mourning his father
people are editing this clip into their
tributes in my culture
death it's not the end
it's my way stepping off point
you reach out with both hands and bust
and segment
they lead you into the green welt where
get around forever sure it's a beautiful
moment delivered perfectly by chadwick
boseman but also one being taken
completely out of context of what this
moment was really about
that sounds very peaceful my father
thought so
i am not my father task force will
decide who brings in barnes
don't bother miss romanov
i'll kill him myself yes also a great
delivery necessary to establish
t'challa's dramatic arc from vengeance
to forgiveness in that particular film
but you see by trimming this clip
well-intentioned folks are already eager
to like re-edit bozeman
out of his context to make their
statement about him
it's like the blood is invisible like i
get if you want to use this as an
example of bozeman's amazing
performances cool cool
but just please stop using this line as
a weird epitaph
anyway marvel comics already has a
tradition in place to pass down a mantle
from one generation
to the next they pass the torch they do
not replace or
erase spider-man passed from peter
parker to miles morales in the ultimate
comics ant-man pass from hank pym to
scott lang
and yes the black panther is a title
inherited by t'challa
from his father t'chaka and then passed
on in recent comics to his sister
sheree by the way i think it's very
telling that marvel recently made shuri
black panther comic story lines
available to read 4-3
shuri taking over the mantle was
probably in marvel's plan for a future
film
definitely not right away though and
yeah i hear the concerns that even that
might feel too soon to some audiences
now there are some ways coogler and
marvel could mitigate that
like a time jump maybe attached prelude
comics to the film giving us accounts of
t'challa's mini heroic adventures maybe
a
tasteful off-screen departure for
t'challa that doesn't minimize it as a
plot point
or try to tie in a new threat with it
maybe some heroic self-sacrifice where
he
saves shuri by transferring that
vibranium necklace to her and maybe
encasing her in his protection as we've
seen marvel heroes do before
now i will say that sharing power like
that is a core theme to black panther
a very impactful one and that power
doesn't have to stop at shuri
she could take on an even younger
protege to pass that torch onto in the
future
i i don't know i'm just gonna trust
marvel to take
its time consult with the cast consult
with bozeman's loved ones
figure out the most respectful and
impactful way forward
don't try to rush any logical fixes like
oh we got it the character will die
defending wakanda from neymar
or we'll use this to introduce the x-men
no no thanks i don't need bozeman's
death to be
exploited for franchise world building
and honestly i don't need black panther
2 to make its may 2022 deadline
it probably wasn't gonna stick to that
anyway just take all the time you need
and for all of you watching let me know
what you think the most appropriate way
forward is and please try to keep it
civil in those comments
obviously this is a very difficult thing
to talk about but uh before i go just a
little reminder that new rock starts
tomorrow we'll be doing a live watch
party for the dc
fandom event our good friend hector
navarro is hosting the live stream here
on new rockstar's youtube channel
tomorrow covering all the panels and
reveals
so be sure to tune in for that but as
for this video that's all i have for you
thank you for watching and um to
chadwick bozeman
thank you to staying so strong for us
king
you